- 'Cause you grew up,
not just in the South,
you grew up in the Deep South, right?
- Oh, I grew up in the dirty dirty.
There's the dirty South,
and then there's the dirty dirty
which is where I'm from in Mississippi.
- Yes, yes, I love it.
I grew up in the South as well.
How hard was that growing up
in that kind of environment being gay?
- It was really hard.
- Could you come out then
or did you have to wait?
- I had to wait honestly.
I grew up in a conservative Christian,
ultra ultra red part of the state
and it was really hard for me
to kind of come to grips with that
but I was blessed with
a really loving family
and it wasn't easy for them at first
but we all navigated it together
and came out a stronger family
on the other side of it.
- That's so cool
That can be hard.
'Cause I'm from the South,
from an ultra Christian community as well.
So I had friends that,
I always like asking people
in the limelight about that
because a lot of people don't
have the confidence to do that
so that's why I always ask people,
like how did you do it
or when did you do it.
- I think we're seeing a new South emerge
and I credit people like you, honestly.
I've always appreciated your
support of the LGBTQ community,
I loved your Tie It Up music video
where you have gay couples getting married
along side straight couples in this video
and just showing that love
is love is love, right?
- Love is hard, you know what I'm saying,
like even if you,
just what I say.
Love is hard enough to find
so when you find it who the
hell cares what it looks like.
If you're the same or different.